أريد أن أعرف هل كنت الأقذر، لقد كان
رمزًا لذلك لا نعرف من كان ولكن
من كان الأقل تلوثًا، فقد
شرعنا في تجربة أرشدها
عالم الأغذية بول داوسون لجمع
عينات من منازل
عائلة زملائنا  والأصدقاء لمعرفة أي
مكان في منازلنا يحتوي على أكبر عدد من الجراثيم
في خمسة منازل، قمنا باختبار نفس
الأماكن بعد أربعة أيام من تنظيفها،
حوض المطبخ، تصريف سطح المطبخ،
مقعد المرحاض في الحمام،
مقابض صنبور الحمام، ومدخل
الباب الأمامي، المختبر  عزل
الخلايا البكتيرية وتوثيقها أثناء
تكاثرها في مستعمرات
يمكننا أن نرى أن هذا أمر مقزز حقًا،
أعني الباب الأمامي، خاصة أنه
يبدو فقط، أعني أنه مغطى بشكل صحيح، لقد
كنت قلقًا حقًا عندما تمشي
في الباب الأمامي لتلك الأرض  نظرًا لأننا
نعيش في مدينة نيويورك والأرض
قذرة، فأنت قلق حقًا بشأن
أنه ربما يكون لديك ممسحة يمكنك
تنظيفها بشكل دوري، وقد
أكدت تجربتنا غير العلمية أن عقودًا من
الميكروبات البحثية بما في ذلك البكتيريا تعيش في كل مكان
حولنا ونحن على دراية بها
خطرة مثل السالمونيلا الليستيريا والإشريكية القولونية
بالإضافة إلى الفيروسات التي لم
نختبرها ولكن ليست كل الجراثيم سيئة في
الواقع معظمها جيد بالنسبة لنا وبعضها
يساعد أجسامنا على أداء وظائفها. الشيء الذي
يفاجئ الناس أكثر بشأن الجراثيم الموجودة في
منازلهم هو  أن أطول مدينة هي على الأرجح
أنظف مكان في
منزلهم، لذا فإن الأماكن التي نحضر فيها
طعامنا كانت أقذر من
مقعد المرحاض. أود أن أقول نعم بالتأكيد،
توصي المؤسسة الوطنية للصرف الصحي باستخدام محلول مبيض ضعيف
لتعقيم مصارف المطبخ والتخلص منه
مرة واحدة  حاول
استبدال الإسفنجة في كثير من الأحيان في كل شهر،
فالإسفنجة
ملوثة بدرجة كبيرة بالبكتيريا
والعفن وهذا أمر ممتع، لقد استبدلت الإسفنجة
كل أسبوع بحيث كان
عمر الإسفنجة ثلاثة أيام فقط، نعم من المستحيل
إزالة جميع البكتيريا الموجودة فيها.  سنكون
موجودين بغض النظر عن المغزى من ذلك،
فمعظم البكتيريا غير ضارة أو
إيجابية، وهناك عدد قليل منها غير ضار،
وهنا يأتي دور الصرف الصحي